buonasera a tutti il titolo il tema di
questa giornata
di questo ha detto
due più due uguale a 5 mi ha interrogato
molto
in realtà mi ha messo anche un pochino a
disagio non non mi sentivo proprio sul
pezzo non mi sentivo proprio sul tema
e questo per due ragioni in particolare
luna perché ho l'impressione che questa
formula non debba nemmeno essere più
dimostrata viviamo in un contesto
viviamo in un quadro nel quale due più
due
pare che possa fare solo 5 tutto
matematica finanziare lettronica
digitale realtà aumentata
2 più 2 5 e quasi il perimetro di gioco
di una cittadinanza di un accreditamento
possibile e io certo in questo centro
poco perché io vengo da un paese così il
mio in particolare 60 abitanti 800 metri
di altezza nell'appennino reggiano nel
cuore dell'appennino tosco emiliano
ma il mio c'entra poco queste succiso
1000 metri di altezza 25 chilometri di
distanza dall'altro primo centro abitato
e di servizi certo qui con la matematica
non si scherza i conti si fanno in
piazza tutti i giorni e ogni giorno si
guadagna quello successivo lo scorrere
della vita che guadagna il suo spazio è
certo i numeri sono complicati nel 1920
un terremoto nel 1954 una frana l'ha
obbligata essere ricostruita e tutti i
suoi abitanti migrarono più su più a
monte in un posto secondo loro più
identitario e più sicuro e mille
abitanti circa un secolo fa e oggi 64 si
qua con la matematica non si scherza c'è
poco da aumentare qua i conti devono
tornare per il loro per la loro sostanza
per il loro essere anche qui a rione
sanità certo da succiso in cima a un
monte nell'appennino reggiano nel cuore
di una città ma anche qua con i numeri
non si scherza non si scherza qua con i
numeri e non non ne cito in questo caso
tanto che gli abitanti
gli stessi fanno fatica a chiamare casa
il rione sanità
gli abitanti stessi sono impauriti molto
spesso in molti casi di ciò che si qua
si potrebbe fare o si potrebbe ancora
raccontare
sì qui in queste zone c'è poco da
puntare a un risultato aumentato qui già
far di conto
è una battaglia quotidiana
qui certo ogni giorno si deve attendere
attendere in una veglia profonda comune
importante perché il giorno successivo
possa venire qui il cammino serve per
tenere aperta la strada altrimenti i
rovi la invadono facilmente qui il
racconto le storie servono per tenere in
vita i personaggi per tenere in vita le
persone
ebbene proprio queste storie si sono
interrotte
la gente in questi luoghi esclusi dalla
realtà aumentata del addensamento di
dove tutti andavano ha smesso di
attendere il giorno successivo
qui la gente ha smesso il racconto e i
personaggi sono morti da questa da
questo e da questa interruzione da
questo strappo
qui la gente ha smesso di camminare e
sentieri si sono chiusi per gli abitanti
per i turisti per chiunque li voglia
cagli li vuole camminare
ebbene qui c'è poco da attendere
risultati clamorosi ed eclatanti qui
l'intuizione è stata quella di
riprendere il racconto semplicemente
riprendere il racconto là dove era stato
interrotto ad esempio dario torri a
succiso nel 1991 il bar ultima attività
del paese ma soprattutto ultimo luogo di
conversazione e di parola ultimo luogo
in cui le persone si potevano dire in
comune insieme ancora vive sì il bar
chiudeva chiudeva per una ragione
razionale non c'era una ragione al mondo
perché quel bar potesse ancora stare
aperto semplicemente una regola
elementare
loro volevano il bar aperto e lo hanno
fatto l'hanno fatto a mani nude non sono
andati dal sindaco non sono andati dal a
protestare da qualche parte a qualche
istituzione in città altrove a valle
nemmeno col barista che l'aveva chiuso
lui dario torre insieme ad alcuni suoi
coetanei della loro pro loco si è tirato
su le maniche ha riaperto il bar è poi
andato dal notaio ha fatto una
cooperativa poi in banca a firmare con
le case dei genitori a garanzia ha
ripreso il racconto il bar è rimasto
aperto oltre quella chiusura razionale
delle formule matematiche finanziarie
delle realtà razionate scritta altrove
ed è aperto da 29 anni attorno a quel
bar a quella ragione semplice elementare
altri numeri siano stati scritti 700mila
euro di fatturato all'anno sempre lì il
paese ha sempre 64 abitanti senza fare
un passo fuori dall'abitato centinaia e
centinaia di turisti migliaia di turisti
che tutti gli anni arrivano lì proprio a
succiso così come vanno anche nelle
catacombe del rione sanità
qui la visione è stata quella di padre
antonio la visione era quella che quelle
catacombe erano di chi abitava di sopra
e questo avrebbe interessato la storia
ha ripreso di lì una riconsegna di un
bene popolare alla sua gente ai giovani
che avevano fiato ancora per raccontarla
con la storia
quei giovani hanno imparato un mestiere
nelle catacombe li di sotto e loro
laddove non andava nessuno
poche centinaia di turisti in una città
come napoli piena di gente tutto l'anno
accompagnati da quei giovani che con
loro dialetto in tutte le lingue del
mondo raccontano le catacombe e
raccontano con l'emozione di chi proprio
lì sopra abita bene le catacombe anno
riaperta riaperto con loro una parte
anche del rione sanità
sì il quartiere ha capito ha compreso
che è anche da lì c'era del buono per
e si poteva accogliere riprendendo a
vivere così come barbara maffei
ingegnere elettronico a milano è tornata
il racconto che le interessava era
quello delle vedove di appella un
piccolo paese fantasma ormai della
lunigiana
leila riaperto ha ripreso quasi a quel
racconto ne ha fatto un albergo diffuso
e oggi appella è uno dei luoghi più
visitati lunigiana così come i briganti
del cerreto cerreto alpi anche lo anche
loro in un paesino di montagna i loro
numeri si sono due più due anche loro e
ben più di cinque forse fanno due
ritornanti di giovanili se ne andavano
solo via non tornava più nessuno due di
questi sono ritornati da genova e da
un'altra città reggio emilia lì vicino
ma due un altro numero importante due
figli sono nati e non se ne sono andati
si sentono piangere per i cioccolati
cerreto alpi e ha ripreso vita nel
racconto del degli adulti pur così come
quello di questi ragazzi a perugia
appassionati di cinema semplicemente
hanno riaperto una sala cinematografica
premiata quest'anno al festival del
cinema di venezia come la migliore la
migliore gestione gestione
cinematografica in italia la loro
intuizione è stata che quella sala
doveva essere di tutti per poter
rimanere aperta perché le ragioni della
chiusura
anche in quel caso erano razionali e
quanti ne chiudono di sale
cinematografiche
allora i primi 20 mila euro questo il
numero magico per loro 20 mila euro due
più due
li hanno voluti dai 150 stanti sono
stati alla fine porta a porta abitanti
del loro quartiere li potevano chiedere
ad una banca ad una fondazione
filantropica li potevano chiedere ai
genitori li avrebbero ottenuti ma il 100
per cento della loro fiducia di poter
fare il loro progetto veniva dalla
possibilità di raccogliere a porta a
porta da tutti gli abitanti da una parte
degli abitanti del loro quartiere
quella sala adesso aperta loro hanno la
loro passione in mano quel quartiere
una storia ancora da raccontare
è un luogo comune da condividere così
come i ragazzi di scary a tiriolo in
mezzo alla calabria di la passione è
stata quella di scoprire sotto i loro
piedi scavi dei bretti popolo antico
hanno costituito una cooperativa
affascinati dall'idea che quella cosa
poteva essere loro insieme a quel punto
al fondo lo sguardo hanno scoperto altro
terreni incolti la leggenda di ulisse
sul monte tiriolo piuttosto che tessuti
e telai antichi che potevano riprendere
il loro corse da lì hanno ripreso la
storia è volata via molto molto lontano
forse la prima realtà comunitaria che
gestisce incaricata dal ministero un
polo museale ma il sogno più bello è
quello dei bambini di zingonia area
metropolitana vicino a bergamo zingonia
e un area che vista da fuori sembra
persa a se stessa la vita a qualsiasi
forma a quel si fa a qualsiasi formula
qualsiasi realtà ridotto aumentata che
sia ma se andiamo dentro a zingonia
la troviamo viva viva di persone che ne
raccontano in strada la quotidianità
questi bambini non sono tanti sono pochi
senz'altro la matematica gli darebbe
torto ma la loro forza gli dà ragione il
loro sogno perché si siedono in cerchio
nel loro parco insieme agli adulti per
cacciare gli spacciatori e loro seduti
nel loro parco seduti fuori dalle strade
a giocare cacciano gli spacciatori si
loro stanno vincendo e una di queste
bambine
proprio alcuni giorni fa presentando la
loro esperienza ha saputo dire che le
piantine quando nascono proprio quelle
sono belle come loro come le città in
modo elementare ci siamo detti le a
zingonia che la parola più fedele deve
essere data ai bambini e bisogna essere
fedeli alla parola dei bambini come
quando gli facciamo vedere cos'è una
città dai cartonati alla scuola
dell'infanzia quella dove c'è
tra del negozio la bottega l'ufficio
postale il sindaco con la sua fascia e
un bambino può riconoscere i luoghi
certo i bambini hanno bisogno di una
realtà semplice di una realtà in cui due
più due
qualsiasi bambino correggerebbe alla
lavagna questa formula non può che fare
anche mia figlia mi ha corretto tutte le
sere in cui ho provato a preparare
questo incontro con voi ma in realtà se
ripetendo calvino le città sono sogni e
sono invisibili
allora ben più 5 farà la nostra somma
insieme in paesi che sembrano
dimenticati esclusi dal terreno di gioco
di quella formula aumentata dove non ci
interessa più quel 5 per che sarà
inimmaginabile sconfinata la nostra
città se le categorie del vivere le
categorie economiche che sapremo
operativamente rimettere insieme
leggendole nel profondo delle persone
leggendole nei loro occhi nei loro sogni
saranno appunto desideri paure sogni
come quelle della città invisibili di
calvino che noi tutti i giorni possiamo
scrivere ovunque perché questo è il
territorio da riconquistare
perché la realtà prima che aumentata
possa essere vera e vera per tutti
grazie
[Applauso]